hello reject nation we have a special
matrix video
for you guys mr anderson
why would you interrupt my intro
what's going on reject nation okay so
this is uh this is gonna be like a
pretty fun video i imagine and a
personal one for me because the matrix
is my favorite movie of all time you
guys might have heard me declare that
many times over the years what happened
was uh there's a certain team over at
warner brothers who reached out to me
and allowed me to get involved in an
opportunity involving the matrix cast
they allowed me to ask them some matrix
trivia questions i submitted over just a
few you know like they're busy people so
it can only be like five or six
questions gave them multiple choice just
to make life easier but when i got the
footage back uh it was like 250
gigabytes of footage it was a lot i
wanted to just dive into it and just
watch all of it but then i realized wait
a minute wait a minute we do reactions
here so i was like i gotta get my
trinity on camera with me today and we
have to do a reaction to the footage so
i hired my buddy eric over at nerd
chronic to edit down a video for us he
took all the footage made an assembly
cut so we can react to it i'm going to
do a separate upload of just the video
itself of just the trivia as well i
wanted to experience this for the first
time along with all of you reacting to
them answering my trivia questions
already got tickets from matrix
resurrections a while ago i'm very much
looking forward to it now let's see what
they gotta
[Music]
say let's try it let's try no pressure
fine
what is the name of the trading program
everyone fails the first time
jump program
oh i'm sorry
[Music]
good choices hey a a jump program
well they all got it ah that's good you
gotta start out with comments what are
the rules like this is is there a buzzer
no
you got this yeah yeah i want it to be a
contest
i know for sure so i'm gonna definitely
have to confirm no pressure
[Music]
what was the name of the book neo uses
to hide the hard drive it gives a toy
i know this one but i'm not going to
like
i know this answer what is it d
b
now i felt something at least you're
feeling something i'm blank the
neromancer you had a gun
all right
i kind of knew that too
[Music]
that was my second choice this arm was
like what are you saying this one was
like hey this one's like no i actually
knew them all before you did that
what is the number of the door on the
room trainees at the beginning
[Music]
it's room 101 damn you know
i don't know why 303 jumped out of my
pocket was it your left hand or your
right hand it was the right hand
wow keanu knew that one is keanu and one
is trinity and the o is bringing them
back together in a cycle of
or three you turn it sideways
[Music]
mom
what was your point
i think it's a 303.
[Music]
[Applause]
it's 303 it's race oh my god i went to
1984. i knew it what i didn't remember
the answer
i wrote it i quit you gone uh okay i
lost all my points you all you all saw
that
[Music]
know myself
divine
know they solve
hey everyone knew that one yeah i knew
it
oh
good timing
okay we're getting into the groove of it
now guys okay i just had to get a
recovery i got a new day so what are the
choices
what is the first line spoken by
morpheus in the matrix
[Music]
i have hills for you guys i have pills
for you
i think i got
yeah your dummy answers are good cubicle
right i believe right he's in the
cubicle and he's like who is this
colonial
it's hello neo yup
i thought it was yes sequence was the
first day of filming on the matrix it
was in the office and it's when agent
smith is coming in the wachowskis were
working with the city cam that day
because they had a lot of shots to make
and i remember it was at the end of the
day
and they were walking away and i was
walking behind them and they were both
walking
and they without even looking at each
other
we got this
[Music]
i'm going to just pause this really fast
look at the answers
too late dodge this not just human
welcome to the maker
i was like
what is the goofiest line i could think
of that you could say
the
[Music]
everyone knows that one dodge this
everyone knows that one classic
all right
anticipation
no that one i really knew okay do it do
it do it do it
do it go ahead do it only human
dodge this
so cool what exactly is the red pill
[Music]
it's a placebo yeah yeah
it's definitely not the anxiety pill
trace program logically if you think
about it hey
reality pill i think it's a trace
program so that they can get you to
reality
hey
it's a trace program yeah of course oh
i mean yeah right
i can't believe it
awesome that was fun
that was fun well done i need to confirm
if did i give the wrong correct answer
let me check that out i might if i might
have watched that for them oh no we're
logging on to hbobx.com
it's their job to know though
i thought that it was room 101
i thought it was two thousand one yeah
your credibility
was there a mix up here or something
happening oh no dude all right go right
to the beginning
i wrote it i wrote the answers
and i was even like it's one of one guys
make anybody look like a fool cause i
was like yeah
i mean we didn't need to see keanu's
answer on the right of course he knows
the answer to that one he experienced it
in the movie he's done enough red pills
in his life ah that was so much fun that
was a blast yeah i love how confident
yahya is yeah man
trust me i know this
the whole time but their chemistry
together jonathan groff looks like he
was having a blast i love how keanu and
jada pink and smith i don't think i've
ever seen them do an interview side by
side together and then i love how he
just broke off into stories and
it was great i was i was happy to see
them have fun like you have to think of
something that involves the cast so i
was like all right what involves the
cast here and and i thought this would
be a fun collective experience to do and
i think eric did a great job out of this
town yeah it was a lot of it's a lot of
shots and a lot of footage and then uh
gigabytes you did a great you did a
fantastic job editing this down yeah
what did you guys get did you guys get
all the answers correct you're going to
want to watch that video back there's
some funny answers in there yeah i'm
really really proud about the i brought
you some pills
on top of that i want to give them
something that will make them laugh
oh yeah so i was really happy that made
them laugh yeah yeah with the whole like
hey you you wanted to do this that was
great that made me very very happy that
they left at that that was an honor just
just to know like even on some of the
behind-the-scenes footage you know like
the person asking the questions are like
this is from the real rejects and and so
just looking at that behind the scenes
footage just made me so happy like i
can't believe the saying the real
rejects asking these guys questions
cameron's like okay
for real reach
i will subscribe that was a blasty blast
thank you guys so much uh for being here
wouldn't have this opportunity to be
able to ask the cast of one of my
favorite franchises of all time some
great questions here john thanks for
being here delighting in this with me
thank you for having me i'm just so
excited for you this is awesome uh guys
make sure to uh subscribe click that
bell uh i'll upload this in in full for
you all and we'll catch you guys soon
thank you